hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from yesterday's aim
chest preliminaries we have a game
between another Beck abdusaparov and
gukesh and as you know anotherbeck is
the world rapid champion and this is a
rapid time format so this is a
definitely uh right up his alley and uh
he lost one game he had a perfect first
day he won three games in one draw but
then he started the second day by a loss
against Village and bookish is still
undefeated and he in the last two games
he defeated Anish giri and Hari Krishna
so it's quite the matchup it's quite the
game you guys will enjoy it let's check
it out so another back has the white
pieces and he opens with Pawn to D4 and
also this is a great opportunity for
Lucas to get back at another back for
beating him at the uh Olympiad so D4 we
have Knight to F6 C4 sorry about that
uh we have E6 and now Knight to F3 not
going for Knight to C3 allowing the
names of Indian we have D5 uh Knight the
C3 and Bishop to B4 so that goes in
defense we have C capture C captures and
now Bishop to F4 and as the Knight is
not pinned uh you can start the attack
right away Knights the E4 now putting
pressure on the C3 knight uh and now
Rook to A1 uh we have Knights the C6 and
now Knights the D2 and here the the fun
really starts Pawn to G5 now it looks
really crazy but it's not new it has
been played before many times uh for
example Magnus Goss and defeated
Alexander grishuk in this position in
the Saint Louis Blitz in 2020. it was an
online one due to kovid uh where Magnus
played Bishop to E3 but here yeah and
also the bishop to G3 is a known but
here we have Knight D captures and E4 uh
by another back and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so let's see how good cash deals with
this G characters and F4 he goes after
the bishop with A3 now uh trying to get
captures and captures uh but now D
captures on e4 and okay a captures on B3
and now Pawn to E3 starting the attack
right away F captures an E3 Queen to H
for with check G3 and the g captures
um f captures on G3 and now looking at
this it's very hard to uh imagine that a
white would go voluntarily into this but
this is what uh Abdullah prepared uh
King to D2 and now trying to get the
king to the queen side bookish does not
allow it Bishop to F5 now look at this
bishop guarding all of these squares the
queen uh sword of guarding E1 because if
the king ever lands there it it's gonna
get uh crazy and here we have Knight the
B5 going after that C7 Pawn uh but here
uh Abdu Sutter of missed something and
he missed something very important so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find what what he missed while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not going after
the pawn and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's best of the
E4 this is what he missed and there is
no uh there is no coming back from
Bishop to A4 the problem is if you play
Rook to G1 then just G captures on H2
you are not saving this Rook that's not
and not an option and if you go Knight
captures on C7 which is the only option
pretty much then King E7 and after you
captured The Rook now Rook to d8 you are
not in a rush to capture this rook and
the white has to be very careful Knight
D4 captures captures the queen hangs uh
anything is possible here and if Queen
E1 preventing the capture you just play
Bishop captures on H1 anything but now
Queen captures on G3 Queen captures age
captures Rook capture 78 uh you are up a
full piece as you can see uh black has a
knight white a dozen so that was
possible but uh Abdullah managed to
trigger
d8 right away he did not go for this
bishop to E4 move First bishop to G2 now
now Abdullah no longer allows it and
then now Queen to G5 interestingly if
Google wants he can force a draw here
with Knight captures and D for it's uh
Unstoppable uh just a rook capture Sandy
fortnite captures Queen captures the
king cannot go to C2 you have to play
King U1 and now Queen F2 check and we
have a nice repetition here so if Lucas
wanted he could have forced a draw here
but he wants the fight he plays Queen to
G5 and who wouldn't I mean look at that
King on D2 uh not Knight captures on C7
with check King to f8 and now Pawn to D5
Abdu Sutter of just advancing his pawns
like his king is not on D2 We have Queen
to E7 and now Knight back to B5 Queen
captures and B4 check now for King the
Knight and Knight back to C3 and now uh
it's a very tricky position you you
should play something like Rook G8 or G
characters on H2 but Lucas plays a rook
cap Queen captures on B2 and while it's
a nice move it does allow abdusatrov to
defend King to E1 and now Knights the B4
not defend completely this is still
winning for hooker but not after Knight
to B4 here you have to play Rook to G8
uh and you you are still fighting for
the win but after night the B4 he gives
him an opportunity although he doesn't
take a queen to D2 sort of uh uh defense
as uh after night the knights the C2
check you free up the D1 Square for the
king here it's very very tricky Abdullah
plays E4 but I mean what a position look
at this Knight the D3 check now if he
captures on D3 Queen to not E2 Queen to
F2 is Checkmate so uh of course Queen
captures on D3 we have Queen captures on
C1 with check uh the pawn prevents the
king from coming to F2 so Knight to D1
and now Bishop back to G6 but not just
Queen to D4 a very nice centralizing
move by Abdus and all of a sudden it's
not as clear I mean black is better but
the two pawns are are very very strong
and The Rook still has to find the way
into the game so King to G8 uh defending
the rook and now H captures on G3 we
have Queen to G5 and now King to F2
defending the G3 Pawn Rook to E8 putting
pressure on e4 and Knight to E3 now we
have Queen to E5 putting more pressure
on E for offering a queen trade and up
shuttle just grabs the pawn on A7 King
to G7 and now Rook to H4
adding another Defender here also you
can shift The Rook to F4 if needed but
now B5 Gooker starts advancing the past
pawn queen to C5 we have rooked the B8
putting the Rook behind the pass pawn
and now Knights the G4 very unpleasant
move as the F6 and H6 squares are now
also guarded by the Knight and if the
black queen ever leaves this diagonal a
move like Queen to D4 or queen to C3
check will be deadly so uh Queen to B2
and now we have Ponte E5 cutting off the
Queen's uh uh reach over this diagonal
Pawn to H5 not trying to uh well
relocate the Knight so you can capture
an E5 but now abdusadra finds Queen to
E7 uh point being that if the Knight is
captured Queen F6 check and after the
king moves you just get the checkmated
so after Queen E7 Rook the B6 is played
adding a Defender across the sixth rank
but now Pawn to D6 Ponte E6 looks scary
but it's actually really fine for black
if Queen D4 check E3 you can just play
Queen E1 you don't care if captures just
Rook to f8 Black is perfectly fine here
but after D6 it is much much harder to
play this because now Queen to D4 check
Knight to E3 and now Queen to C5 not
allowing the pawn to move
uh the pawn is an E5 so F6 square is
guarded so Queen to F6 with check King
to G8 and now Bishop to D5 with the
thread of Queen captures on G6 so Rook
to H6 stopping this but now just Rook
captures on H5 the absolute strongest
move this is a forced Checkmate Bishop
captures now Queen captures an H6 and it
was in this position and move 40 uh that
wukish I believe lost on time but uh
even if he didn't even if he resigned
it's it's a forced Checkmate there's
nothing you can do there's no saving the
bishop and also there are more important
things than the bishop whatever you even
if playing Knight G4 because the Knight
is pinned still just Queen G4 check now
if king of faded Queen captures on F7 is
Checkmate so you go here now you don't
even capture the bishop you just play
Bishop captures on F7 and there's no
defense against Queen H6 Checkmate and
queen to G8 Checkmate so really a wild
wild game Abdus
decided to mix it up after this G5 move
he prepared this Knight captures on each
before he was saving it for who knows
how long it was now against wilkesh that
he employed it and it seems it was much
much harder to deal with this than yeah
than previously thought even though uh
like I said previously just Bishop to E3
and Bishop to G3 are played these are
the only moves that the engine says that
give advantage to white but Knight
captures I need for uh the engine deems
as an immediate equalizer for black uh
but of course if you play it uh like an
engine uh apple cider prepared it well
and did not find the best way out of the
out of the deep deep dark force that
followed uh so yeah and that's the game
I hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by Abdullah who is the leader even
after the second day so he was the
leader after the first day now he leads
after the second day Magnus caught him
at some point uh but um it didn't take
as abdulsarov just continued crushing
everyone and now he's the leader and
followed by mamidarov and he has 17
points mamajarovan Magnus with 16 points
then with 15 we have Yankees to do that
Arjun irrigation Vincent kaimer and
anishagiri which 12 points so those are
the top eight and as these are the
preliminaries the top eight go ahead but
there's still one more day so uh we'll
see what happens uh if the others can
catch up or will these guys stay in the
top eight uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Francis Sarah
woman life freedom and Lord of chests
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day